when looking at a cast of characters in
an anime some people just make a bigger
impression you often have the loud
character or the big guy you know those
guys that you typically would expect to
explode in a flurry to save their
friends however today's list
is not about those people to be honest
i'm a bit more partial to the karma
characters on the side of the spectrum
after all they make good candidates for
today's list which is going to be about
some top moments of a calm character
just snapping and raising hell to shake
things up a little bit though i'm not
limiting this list to the full
introverted characters i also want to
feature some extroverted or outgoing
protagonists who may not be as loud as
their mentioned counterparts consider
this a spiritual successor to the top
rage moments or a retake if you're new
to the channel and haven't seen those
videos yet if you fall in the latter
especially i'd like to ask you a little
favor
and to hit that subscribe button if you
haven't done so already now let's begin
levi's know erin that's for sure and i
don't even think that i'll be able to
remain composed considering all the
things he's been through in the whole of
attack on titan however when he gets
into the zone of raging fury there's
little anyone can do to stop levi he's
got several of these moments but i'd
like to feature the ova moment because
it's one of those early instances and
it's something that fewer people might
know about after all
i'm sure everyone and their children
already know about him going ham on the
beast titan seriously though this moment
from the ova is more emotional than
anything you can just feel the power in
the scene and it further exemplifies the
things that levi had to endure to mold
him into the strongest soldier that we
know and love losing friends is never
easy but hearing levi's scream and the
pure emotion being channeled in this
scene
gave me the chills
[Music]
talking about levi really reminded me of
roy mustang it must be the similarities
in backgrounds but i think they had
comparable rage moments where they just
go to town against their enemies
however i'd say that amongst the many
scenes of mustang kicking homunculus ass
the execution of envy is by far the
angriest he's ever been
poor envy didn't even get to finish his
gloating before mustang appears and
incinerates him
people call this a fight but as i've
said in the numerous times i've talked
about this before
it's not one it's truly no contest
really and we see that even a homunculus
power is useless in the face of repeated
unadulterated violence from an
angry mustang yeah you could argue that
in some way mustang c may not be as
emotional as levites
but in terms of the distraction that
happened i dare to say
that this one's more impressive
okay how about we move to main
characters now then gone comes to mind
you all know what i'm talking about who
could forget this iconic moment when
gone fights beto and taps into his inner
abyss
showing the way past the friendly and
outgoing facade of gone there lies a
darkness that he'd kept hidden for so
long it's truly a horrific yet cathartic
moment to see gon finally access this
side of him and it's pretty cool because
unlike levi or mustang's moments you can
still see an unsettling calmness in gone
scene despite him falling completely
into nihilism there's a sense of
controlled frenzy
that's the best way to describe it and
because of that the moments found its
way into many people's top hunter hunter
moments
before we move on to the next moment i'd
like to take time to thank our sponsors
for today's video
expressvpn expressvpn is the number one
vpn service that allows you to access
the internet like never before that
includes being able to watch all of
those shows legally
even if you're not in the supported
region because we all know that region
locks can be such a pain
yes even in other countries with tighter
measures on internet
expressvpn has been my number one
partner and friend
one of the things preventing me from
having one of those aforementioned rage
moments of my own out of frustration
i've used expressvpn to rewatch attack
on titan recently
and let me just say that it boasts one
of the most simplest interfaces that
i've ever seen for a vpn
just turn on this bad boy and select the
united states server connect
and enjoy some titan slaying goodness i
also want to add the express vpn proudly
presents top tier protection for your
data
this way you can browse the internet
without worry despite the growing
worries on cyber security these days and
i would love you to join the fun so
don't forget to click on the link in the
description box or go to expressvpn.com
vini tube to get started on a new safer
internet life for you
now let's head back to the video
jiu jitsu kaizen storied runners come to
an end but not before it gave us an
amazing arc to cap things off what i
like about jujutsu kaizen is that
throughout its run it got the chance to
show us some key moments from the main
characters everyone knows gojo and his
moments but it really feels like one got
left behind as jiu jitsu kaizen wrapped
up a couple of months ago megumi's
moment came in episode 23 when he
finally leaves his comfort zone in the
battle against the curse pushing himself
past his limits with his all-new domain
expansion kimira shadow guarded and i'm
not sure about
you but i feel like it's a surreal sight
to see megumi put off such a dark and
ominous looking ability while bleeding
with that crazed face on everything from
visuals to the voice acting came
together to make this
a scene to remember it came late in the
show's run but jujutsu kaizen really
gave us a finale to remember for its
first season
now this one hurt when i first saw it
dora rose seemed to be a standard
fantasy demon hunting series with a
nifty premise but i think the one moment
which sets it apart from the knot came
pretty early on i'm talking about
episode 6 when we get to see the full
glory of a raging hyakimaru who just
tears through everyone in his sight
it's a level of violence and anger that
i didn't think i'd find in the show at
first but hiakimaru makes a whole show
out of the bloodbath that happens in
that episode remembering the scene there
really reminds me of the levi moment
that i talked about but there's
something just so much more unsettling
with how doraro did it maybe
because the violence was done not
against monsters or demons but people or
maybe because of how much more graphic
it was
anyway this is the very scene that
showed everyone that despite his quiet
and reserved
nature kiakimaru is something you
wouldn't want to trifle with
in a callback to gorn's moment we have
another protagonist embracing the
emptiness within its mob with his
question mark percentage form
among the whole gallery of mob's forms
that tied to his emotions lies the deep
depths of the question mark form an
enormous power that represents the
strength that he repressed in order to
appear normal this
is by far the most terrifying form of
mob no questions asked from the white
and eyes the wildly flaring hair
to the evil looking aura now imagine if
you were some unfortunate slob like
deruki if seeing that format of someone
you've just been beating up moments ago
doesn't give you the creeps i don't know
what will the look on deruki's face
after seeing the frankly terrifying mob
face says it all this new form of mob
literally beats the clothes and hair out
of the kokiteru although i won't say
that he didn't deserve it in each of its
subsequent appearances this forms
unloaded unadulterated destruction
on all that dare to pose it and you'll
quickly understand why the calm and
unimposing mob would prefer attacking
this form away for good it's something
that you should all look out for if
you're someone getting into mob psycho
foreign
it's a no-brainer to end the list with
the show with the greatest fondness for
flipping the switch so to speak gintama
is probably the poster child of anime
that can shift from comedic and goofy to
straight up
epic action and drama no one embodies
that trait better than gintoki himself
for all the goofiness and relative chill
that gintoki has he can turn into an
unstoppable engine of destruction when
the right buttons are pushed as you see
in various instances in the series story
run for me my favorite amongst those
would have to be his fight versus
jirocho the ambiance is perfect
the rain the perfect soundtrack and the
sequencing of events and fight
choreography make this a standout moment
to show
your friends if you can find the fight
in high quality of course this is one of
the most passionate scenes in the series
that i can think of off the top of my
head seriously just watch the clip and
be amazed then
ask yourself this is gintoki on another
note an interesting thing about this
moment is that it's the only moment on
the list that doesn't result in a
victory for the angry man kintoki so
consumed with rage that he never got to
fight properly and reasonably especially
against a monster like jirocho kintama's
not like one of those anime we're
getting angry or fighting for those deer
to
automatically wins you the fight you
know
as i close the list i'm always on the
lookout for scenes like the ones i just
mentioned so i'd love to hear your
suggestions on other scenes that i can
take a look at if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to click the thumbs up and
you're free to check out what the
channel has to offer in addition to the
membership options in the patreon which
i'll be linking in the description box
you can also check out my other channel
vinnie tube kai
vinichukai is my second channel and it's
more focused on video essays and
analysis videos so if you also want to
have a dose of those
especially videos on popular series and
make sure you check it out don't forget
to check out our sponsors of this video
expressvpn bypass all those pesky region
locks and even browse sites not
available in your region
with the ever trustee expressvpn now
that's it for today i hope that i can
see you next time
see ya
you